cases are also climbing fast in another
covet hotspot the state of Arizona that
state reported more than 2,500 new cases
yesterday and over the past seven days
nearly 27% of the tests there have come
back positive that is the highest rate
in the nation
ICUs are nearly full and the state is
preparing for the outbreak to get much
worse mola lankey is in Mesa Arizona
that's just outside Phoenix molla good
morning what are the latest and newest
concerns there oh good morning Tony you
know we're at one of the 24-hour testing
sites here in Arizona in a state that
has become a virus hotspot you see one
vehicle right there being tested but you
know for so many folks finding places
like this and getting tested is still a
challenge especially for the hard-hit
low-income communities health officials
tell us the testing is still critical
this as just yesterday on Sunday an
additional 86 people died here in
Arizona from kovat 19 yeah was your in
the living room and I was like you're
going to the hospital Marissa Lopez and
her half-brother Luke birds say they
knew as they sent their 63 year old
mother Kimberly to the hospital that it
might be the last time they ever saw her
alive and before she went I was like
Luke we need to give mom a hug and tell
her we love her because we don't know
what's gonna happen yeah
this may be it I mean we were right it
was it Kimberly Lopez Byrd was an
elementary school teacher in Phoenix and
was teaching summer school online she
was sharing a classroom with two other
teachers when she came down with the
virus how bad is it here well I mean we
have for the last three weeks been the
worst in the entire country will humble
is the former director of the Arizona
Department of Public Health and says his
state was on the right track at first
but then reopened too quickly people
sacrificed so much during the stay at
home order with their jobs and then when
it wasn't fazed as we transitioned into
a post stay at home we lost that
progress Phoenix Mayor Kate Gallego on
CBS's Face the Nation Sunday said she's
calling on the governor to issue a
statewide mask
and eight restaurants to serve takeout
only and the closure of personal care
services like nail salons we think
that's just not necessary right now
while you're seeing such high levels of
the virus another looming situation
facing Arizona the opening of schools
set for next month they just don't feel
like it's a safe environment for
teachers to go in and they're concerned
about our students as well as spread of
the virus Education Secretary Betsy
DeVos who has threatened to pull federal
funding for schools that don't reopen
downplayed the risk and addressed
concerns of children spreading the virus
there is no nothing in the data that
would suggest that kids being back in
school is is dangerous to them just be
aware for Marissa Lopez and Luke Byrd
they know all too well the potential
price of opening schools too soon we're
basically blatantly putting them at risk
for something that's basically it's we
can revive our children's education
we can't revive a life the other two
teachers who worked in the same
classroom as Kimberly Byrd also
contracted the virus it's not known
exactly how but they are still
recovering the school district tells CBS
News that they are strictly following
CDC guidelines the family tells us that
they do believe that meanwhile top
public health officials tell us that
it's still early they just don't know
yet exactly how this virus impacts
children and how efficiently they're
able to spread the virus Gayle I'm still
struck my Mullah by her last comment you
cannot provide a life thank you very
much